[Music]
um
is
[Music]
audio test
okay hello everyone uh welcome to
uh my talk titled recent progress in
quantum benchmarking
my name is lin chan i'm a student here
at berkeley and this is joint works with
colleagues from uchicago
so let's get started
so quantum benchmarking refers to the
effort of
designing algorithms to learn about
noise in our quantum devices
so this term has been used in broader
contexts but here we will focus on
learning quantum noise
so this figure shows a quantum computer
that we have today
on ibm's website
and we can see there are 27 qubits and
the color on each edge
indicates the total amount of noise that
will happen if we implement a c naught
gate on that edge so we can also see the
error distribution here most gates are
fine but there are some outstanding
errors
so this is exactly the kind of things
that we will be doing
so why do we care about benchmarking
because we need to know what the noise
looks like in our device in order to
further reduce them and build better
quantum computers
as well as perform error mitigation in
near term experiments and eventually
designing suitable error correcting
codes for tolerance
so currently we have quite mature
methods to estimate the total error on a
single gate which is what we just saw
and in today's devices
the single qubit gates are quite good
they only have 10 to the minus 3 to 10
to the minus 4 error
but the two qubit gates are noisy
so in order to handle this we basically
need to perform benchmarking on these
skates
and obtain knowledge about the noise and
finally use this knowledge to reduce the
noise
so let's start by clarifying what is
noise
in general noise just means that what we
want is to implement some ideal
operation let's say a c not gate on our
device but what actually happened in
experiments it's just some other
operation
but of course we can
model it formally
and it will be something like this so we
still have this ideal operation a c
naught gate
and it will be attached by a
unknown quantum channel lambda
and we can look at this quantity
under some suitable norm the distance
between lambda and the identity channel
is what we refer to as the total error
okay so informally
basically there are two ways we can go
from here
so we have mature methods to estimate
this number on a single gate
and basically we can try to learn more
information on two qubits this will be
the topic of part one
and we can also try to learn the total
error on more qubits
in part
two
okay so for part one what we really want
to know is what exactly does the channel
lambda looks like
so the immediate challenge here is that
a general quantum channel is too
complicated
why does the noise happen before the
temperature
oh it's just a conventional use it's not
important
yeah so the immediate challenge here is
that the general quantum channel is too
complicated even for two qubits
but interestingly we can use this
well-known technique called poly
twirling to simplify the noise
so here is how this works let's
start with the cleaver circuit and let's
just insert
random polygates in each layer
and logically we can propagate all of
the targets to the last layer and we can
correct it
and in this way
the noise on each layer of the gates
will be effectively twirled into a poly
channel this means that using this
technique we can simplify the noise to a
poly channel
which is just a probability distribution
on all of the party operators without
changing the logic of the circuit so we
have
now we have a simpler problem to deal
with
okay so now let's just look at a single
synod gate and we have performed
polytory
in this figure so this is just a
polynoise
and we also have ways to measure the
total error which is this just the sum
of all of the 15 individual errors
and the goal is just to learn
exactly what this 16 dimensional
distribution look like
okay so surely this is easy right
but
sorry can you say this again so you said
you can always without loss of
generality just consider polyerrors
when you're considering clippers
yes
okay
so
however it turns out that
even this is not doable
we don't really have the ability to
even learn this 16 dimensional
distribution
and this seems to be a fundamental issue
because somehow there is some intrinsic
symmetry in quantum systems
that makes some of the errors
unlearnable so we could only figure out
part of the distribution but not all of
them
just to follow up on the previous
question is this a non-clifford thing a
just a theoretical question or in
practice you can see that if you put the
noun pivot there it just doesn't tour
this into a polychain
um so in general i think this doesn't
work but we will see some special cases
where this could work in some sense
okay
okay so part one of this talk is
precisely about this issue where we will
give a precise understanding of what
information about noise is learnable for
clifford gates
okay so besides this we also have the
second goal which is to do scalable
benchmarking
so scalable benchmarking means that for
a large system size such as 20 qubits we
want to efficiently estimate the total
error on the entire system and we know
how to do this for clifford gates
so essentially in part two of this talk
we will show how to do this for
non-clipper gates and of course as lynn
just asked
poor reporting doesn't work in general
for clever circuits but here as we will
show later in algorithm we still achieve
some sort of effective product
so for the purpose here we can still
think of noise as a polygon and we just
want to learn the total error which is
simply 1 minus p
identity tensor n
okay so
the total error is just a single number
so why is this number interesting
well first of all it is non-trivial
because
to compute
to estimate the total error we cannot
just add up the total error on each
individual gate such as these three
gates
this is because the errors in this
circuit can be correlated across
different gates and adding up wouldn't
be the correct estimate
but
what i really want to say here is that
sometimes the total error can provide
deep insights into the noise model
so a striking example is the recent
google's quantum supremacy experiments
so of course this their work is about
quantum supremacy
but if we look closely into their
arguments they are making this
additional claim that the data they
observed in their experiments suggests
that the noise in their device was
uncorrelated
so this is an absolutely remarkable
claim because we know that from the
benchmarking perspective testing whether
our noise model is correlated or not is
definitely not trivial and yet they are
able to make this claim
so we will understand this better by
thinking about hotel in the second part
so here's the outline
so we will just always think of noise as
the poly channel
acting on the
uh body operators and in part one we
will give a precise understanding of
what information about noise is
learnable for clifford case and after
this we will be under we will be under
uh able to understand the xenophage
and in part two we will show scalable
benchmarking of non-clifford gates to
learn the total error
and after that we will be able to
understand google's claim
okay so let's get started with uh part
one
so let's uh
keep talking about this example
so our goal is just to learn this 16
dimensional probability distribution
and what we know is the following
so we know how to estimate the total
error
and what we want is just uh how large is
the individual errors
but currently we only can learn some of
them but not all
and it's really unclear what's happening
here
and this is the exact issue that we
addressed next
and in fact
we will show that there are these
exactly certain equations that we will
be able to learn from the c9 case
so you can see that this is either some
individual errors or some sums of two
errors
and this is all we can get from the
distribution
in other words
the c market has certain learnable
degrees of freedom and two unknown about
degrees of freedom and we will see why
this is the case
so what is happening here what is the
issue that is causing all of this
trouble
so the main issue is the intrinsic
symmetry in the quantum system which we
can call gauge freedom
so let's uh consider a very trivial
example
suppose we have a trivial quantum system
with noisy initial states and
measurements
and let's suppose we prepare the state
zero
we measure it many times
but at the end we see the outcome one
with probability five percent
okay so clearly something is wrong here
right but what is wrong
well it could be the case that all the
five percent noise comes from initial
states
and it could be the case that all five
percent comes from measurements
and it could be could be the case that
two percent comes from initial state and
three percent comes from
uh measurement and there's really no way
for us to tell the difference
so in other words we can write down this
one-dimensional manifold of noise models
and every point on this manifold is
plausible
and also we can also move from one point
to another along this manifold without
changing the experiment outcomes and
such an operation is called gauge
transformation
so what we consider next is a very
general noise model
where we just have initial states
measurements and gates that are all
subject to unknown quantum noise
and we also make some standard
assumptions that has
single qubit gates are perfect and the
total error is sufficiently small
so in this case we can define the gauge
transformation as this
equation
so the key point here is that we can
easily see that by definition this
transformation does not change any
measurement outcome statistics of our
quantum experiments
and therefore if we have two different
noise models that are related by this
gauge transformation
they are indistinguishable by any kind
of measurements
so what we really need to do here is
just a classification task
so within the entire noise model which
has a lot of parameters
we need to figure out which part is
variable meaning meaning that it's
invariant under any gauge transformation
and can be learned by algorithm and we
also need to figure out which part is
unloadable meaning that it is variant
and there's some gauge transformation
and cannot be learned by any algorithm
so going back to the trivial example we
have this noise model which has two prem
uh two degrees of freedom sb and m
and the learnable part is precisely sp
plus m which is invariant along this
manifold
and this is one degree of freedom and
the other one degree of freedom
will be unlearnable
and our goal is just to complete this
classification for general gate noise
which will be much more complicated than
this
okay
but at this point it's actually really
unclear how do we do benchmarking given
the enormous difficulty that we have
noisy states and measurements
so this here comes the main idea of
benchmarking
somehow we observed that in a quantum
experiment the initial state and
measurement only appears once
but we we can hire a gate many times
and in this way we can exploit this
asymmetry to obtain information about
gate noise
so basically we just do these two
different experiments
and because we have these additional
three gates we will observe some
different statistics in the two
experiments
and if we choose the experiments clearly
we will be able to say that the
difference is only caused by gates and
therefore we can use this difference to
obtain information about gate noise yes
so it's probably not applicable to all
wonderful computations but couldn't you
also use the post measures
yeah exactly so that would be
another
model of experiment and we will focus on
this one for now but what you said is
absolutely
interesting direction that i
could have the chance to mention at the
end
okay
so how do we actually use this main idea
for benchmarking
so the idea is to just uh work in the
fourier domain
so in particular we have this incubate
poly channel which is which just us
happens with the capital pa the poly
operator happens with probability small
pa
and we just want to learn this
distribution
and next we will work in the fourier
domain where
these lambda a coefficients are just the
eigenvalues of this
polynomial channel and the lambda
a's are related to the poly errors by a
fourier transformation
and these are called poly fidelities so
next we will show that
we can learn the poly fidelities or
eigenvalues and then reconstruct the
distribution
so this idea comes from the very
beautiful work of cycle benchmarking
which says that
somehow learning poly fidelities
is the natural way to think about
benchmarking
so here is a cypherbank running
experiment
so in this figure the red boxes
represent the noisy initial states and
measurements the green boxes are random
polygates for twitting and we also have
the synod gates
so let's see how this works by example
so let's try to evolve this poly
operator ix by the second benchmarking
circuit
so what happens is that in the first
step
we
conjugate the party by poly so this will
just pick up some plus minus sign which
we will not worry about
and in the second step it picks up this
eigenvalue lambda x from the poly
channel
in the third step it doesn't change
because we have this little toolbox here
saying that c naught maps x to x
and we can basically keep going
okay
so at this point
what what we can do is that in actual
experiments we can prepare a plus one
eigenstate of ix
at the beginning and estimate the ix
observable at the end and average the
result over random poly
and it is shown that the result can be
written as this simple form of some
coefficient times
lambda x to d
where d is the circuit depth or the
number of
c naught gates
although we don't know this coefficient
aix which comes from the noisy initial
states and measurements we will be able
to learn this
ergonomic lambda ix by performing this
experiment at different depths
which is a reflection of the main idea
of benchmark
but this is absolutely remarkable
because
given all the difficulty in the noise we
can somehow already learn this concrete
parameter about noise
and moreover
the original cycle benchmark also learn
some other specific poly fidelities and
can be used to estimate the total poly
hour
okay
but this is not quite enough yet
and here is an overview of the of the
results
so we will actually augment the cycle
benchmark algorithm with a very simple
trick in order to learn more information
and somehow for the c not gate
this is everything we can learn from
exam
the interesting point here is that
anything beyond this that is not in this
list is unlearnable
so we cannot hope to learn them by any
algorithm
so all of this really comes from the
main results that we introduce next
which is a
classification of learnability using a
graph representation
so what is the graph here
well
let's build it up
so we call this graph the pattern
transfer graph
and this is just nothing more than a way
to represent the mapping between party
operators by the clifford gates
so here let's start with all of the
binary strings as vertices
and so let's start with c naught
oh yeah for the things that are
learnable what is the sample complexity
or and the gate depth complexity
yeah so basically for each equation here
we will be able to learn it with a
constant sample context
but there are many equations here
constant depth a constant sample complex
okay
so c naught maps i x to x and we will
add this edge to the ground
so
what we do here is to map the poly
operator to its pattern so the pattern
means that we just replace i with zero
and x y z is one so we just throw away
the information of x y z
so it goes from zero one to zero one
and we also add this label lambda x to
the edge
so next c naught maps exit y y right so
it still goes from one one to one one
and
we are at this label lambda xc and here
this label corresponds to the input
operator
and similarly we can add yy to xc this
is still one to 1
and there will be another edge with
label lambda yy
but technically there are two edges here
but for simplicity we just write them as
two labels on one edge where we really
need to understand this as two edges
so we can keep going
but this next one is slightly different
because
here i z goes to z z
and therefore it goes from zero one to
one one across different vertices and it
has the label alumni z and finally we
also have this lambda zz
which goes back from one one to zero one
so
on a high level
at the end the graph just looks like
something like this and on the high
level what we end up saying is that
let's think of the noise model as living
on the graph
and somehow the cycles in the graph
which are the colorful edges
are learnable
and cuts which are the blue and red
edges are actually unloadable
and this will be more formal later
but interestingly this also implies that
this simple technique of cycle
benchmarking with trick
is optimal in the sense that it can
learn everything that is learnable
according to this
statement
okay so let's take a quick look of how
this trick works
so here is the new cycle benchmarking
experiment with the only difference is
that we have these additional blue gates
so let's see how they play a role
so we just evolved this operator xc
first step doesn't change second step
picks up the economy search that changes
to yy by the c naught
but at this point
these blue gates can actually rotate the
operator yy back to xc
and in this way we can keep going
with lambda xc squared rotate y rotate
back
okay
so we can see that basically using this
rotation trick we will be able to learn
x lambda x c
and this process has to be indicated in
this part of the graph
and similarly we can also learn lambda
yy
so here is the final example which will
be slightly different because the graph
looks like this right so
if we evolve the poly operator i z here
it picks up the eigenvalue and here it
maps to zz
but at this point can we do the same
thing again
can we use the single qubit gauge to
rotate cz again backway z
and the answer is no
because a single qubit unitary cannot
map z to i
and this is because we have moved from 0
1 to 1 1
and the single qubit rotation trick only
works within the same vertex but not a
cross vertex
but nevertheless we can keep going and
we can just put the identity gates in
the blue and see what happens
so at the next step it will pick up
lambda zz
and then back to iz and then keep going
so what happens here is that we can keep
repeating this cycle
and at the end we will be able to learn
the product lambda z times lambda ic but
not each of them individually
and the main reason for that is because
the pattern changes from zero one to one
one
okay
in other words we can track the
trajectory of the operator it started as
i z it goes to zz backwards and we can
repeat this many times and learn the
products
okay so in general
for incubate cleaver gates this graph
just have
two billion vertices and four to the
edges
and
the vertices corresponds to the
polygrade pattern which is a binary
string
and the reason that we don't need to
record x y z identity is because we can
freely rotate among them within the same
vertex using the single qubit trick
so right now this new observation will
become quite clear which is
we can actually learn the product of
poly fidelities along every cycle in
this graph using cycle benchmark
this is just because we can traverse any
cycle in this graph using the single
qubit trick
and we repeat the cycle many times and
in this way we can learn the products
okay so now a natural intuition is
so we know that every cycle is learnable
so what could be the dual of a cycle on
a graph that is actually unlearnable
so this is precisely what we end up
saying
which is in this graph
the product of poly fidelities along
every cycle is learnable
and the product of poly fidelities along
every cut is another
so we will see what this means
shortly
but actually this is
complete
as a proof because
informally we can think of cycles and
cuts as the basis of the graph that
spans the entire graph space
and this can be made formal if we define
vector spaces associated with the graph
so we can think of the graph space as
the orthogonal direct sum of cycle space
which are linear combination of cycles
and cut space which is a linear
combination of cuts
so having figured out figured out the
basis for what is learnable and what is
unknowable
basically we can take any function of
the noise model and decompose it into
two parts the part in the cycle space
and in the part in cut space
and the function f will be learnable if
and only if it is only in the cycle
space
okay so here is
uh what
the actual classification looks like so
let's take the graph for the c notes
and let's just enumerate cycles and cuts
okay so we have this one cycle and we
can write down lambda x
another small cycle write down lambda d
i
and here there are actually five cycles
because there are fabric edges so we
write down these five parameters
and in this part
uh so
there are four
edges in this part but actually there
are only three independent cycles here
because the fourth cycle will be
generated by the first three cycle so we
write down three equations
and finally three more equations here
okay so that's all of the independent
cycles in this graph what about cuts
well there are just two independent cuts
so for this one
we can write down this equation
so what we mean by the product along the
cut is uh
with product we take the product at one
direction and divide by the other
direction
and this function is unknown because we
can
construct a gauge transformation and
prove that this function changes another
transformation
and there is just one more independent
cuts
but
notice that we are actually already down
here because we have identified 13
equations
in the cycle space and two equations in
the cut space and they add up to 15
which is precisely the total number of
degrees of freedom
and we can conclude that the xenon gate
has certain unlearnable degrees of
freedom and two anonymous degrees of
freedom
okay so there is just one final step
which is
what about the poly errors well let's
just do a fourier transformation and
then
we will skip the calculation we'll be
right down this list of poly errors that
is learnable but it's the same 13
equations as the cycle space
so we can observe that 2 is not that
large compared with 13. so what is the
what does the scaling look like in
general
so in general it looks like something
like this
because it is well known in graph theory
what is the size of the cycle space and
part space so basically the cycle space
has dimension four to the n the number
of edges minus two to the number of
vertices plus c the number of strongly
connected components
and the cut space has dimension two b
and minus c
so
interestingly
we sort of showed that the analog
information only occupies a very small
fraction of the parameter space of the
entire noise model
and this is the situation in general
so the final thing to note is that
cycle benchmarking actually learns all
learnable information about noise and
this is just because we have shown that
learnable information forms a cycle
space
and it is an interesting coincidence to
see that the word cycle appears twice in
this context with slightly different
meaning so in cycle benchmarking the
word cycle usually refers to the clock
cycle which means layers of gates
and cycles that in cycle space the cycle
means the psychosomal graph
okay so the main remaining issue from
here is of course how do we resolve and
learnability
and of course we must make additional
assumptions about the noise model
because in general this cannot be
resolved
and we will discuss this at the end
if time permits about what could be the
reasonable assumptions here to make
yes and that's the end of part one
uh any questions before we go to part
two
yes
about the unknown ability thing that
you're talking about
if does it make sense to introduce a new
ancillar that's a one clean cubic sort
of model and then ask if i can
the parameters
it's not a valid question to ask or yeah
that's a good question so you are asking
if i take a c not get here and then i
add one more and zelda here what does it
look like so basically we can just model
this as a three qubit gate and use the
same result
so you still have the unlearnable
parameters yes
in the sense that if i just took the
gate and i like plugged in a bunch of
different inputs and did tomography
couldn't i reconstruct the
efficiency
no no absolutely not the the real
question there is is that your initial
states and measurements are also noisy i
see so we're still assuming those are
noisy here yeah that's that's the main
reason that is causing all of this got
it
thanks
okay so let's go to the second part
a non-clipper benchmark
so the first thing to talk about is why
do we care about non-preferred gates
the main reason here is because
non-clifford equipment gates are
ubiquitous in current implementations of
new term algorithms and the reason of
that is because
experimentalists want to use the native
to qubit gate on their hardware to
maximize fidelity so they want to use
what whatever gates that they they can
implement with the highest fidelity
for example
the square root i swap get used in this
bqe experiment
and the xyz gates used in this qaoa
experiment they are both non-clipper to
keep it gates
so
the second part is about the algorithm
for estimating the total error in a
layer of non-clipper gates
and the reason that this task is
interesting is because of correlated
errors as we discussed before
so let's let's take a look at one
example of this
so here we have two different noise
models on this picture
on the left hand side
we have two independent errors x
red and x blue
and each of them happens independently
with probability one percent
and on the right hand side we have this
correlated error xx that
both happens together with probability
one percent
so the task is to distinguish between
whether we have the left noise model or
the red noise model but the key point
here is that if we only have access to
local information
if we only know how to estimate the
total noise on each of the individual
gates we cannot tell the difference
because they are always one percent
however if we have access to the total
error we will be able to see that the
left hand side has totally over two
percent and the right hand side has
total error
one percent
so this would be the solution for this
problem
of course so we know that um this task
so we know how to solve this task for
clifford gates using cycle benchmark
and this is based on the structure of
the clifford and polygroup which we have
introduced
but
the main challenge here is that for
non-clifford guests the nice structure
that we have used repeatedly in the
fourier domain disappears
it's really hard to imagine how do we do
scalable benchmarking of arbitrary
non-clifford gates
and in fact we will introduce an
algorithm that is completely different
and it is called rcs benchmarking
so basically
this is just a circuit where we
alternate between different patterns of
the gates and we interleave with high
random single-hit gates
and this is quite different from the
left-hand side because the left hand
side doesn't have any entanglement and
the right right hand side creates lots
of entitlements
also the underlying principle of this
new algorithm is also different it is
based on the scrambling effect of random
quantum circuits which in general
doesn't really care about what kind of
gates we have and that is the
fundamental reason that this algorithm
works for any two big gates
so you must see where this is going
because this circuit is exact exactly
the same kind of circuits
that was used in google's quantum
supremacy experiments
and our motivation indeed comes from
there
so in google's experiment the main thing
that they measure is called the linear
cross entropy
which is defined in the following so if
we take m measurement samples from the
experiment the xcv is just the sum of
the ideal probabilities of these samples
with some normalization
and
so in google's experiment the linear
class entropy is used as a proxy of the
fidelity of their experiment
and this is a key point that we will
come back later
so of course google's experiment is
about quantum supremacy
but they also make the second claim that
the noise in their device was
uncorrelated
and as we discussed earlier this is a
remarkable claim that indicates that
maybe there is something happening in
this experiment that we could take
and use it for benchmarking
so let's
really understand what this claim is
about
so here's what this claim is about so if
we look at this figure there are two
types of data points on this figure so
there are these uh individual data
points represented by the
circles or the crosses and there is also
this black line
okay
so the black line is something defined
by google called
the digital error model
and the definition of that is just we
perform randomized benchmarking to
estimate the total error on each case
and we just multiply the one minus error
for every gate
and i'm calling that frb because it came
from randomized vendor
and the data points is the linear
concentration
so why did google come up with this new
metric digital error model and why is
this relevant at all
this is because if you look at this
product equation it has some sort of
spirit of independence in probability
because we know that independent events
the probability is a product
so here is a reconstruction of
the interpretation of what's going on in
google's experiment
so they were thinking the following
maybe the errors in their device is
uncorrelated in this case
it is reasonable to expect that the
fidelity of the experiment roughly
equals the probability of no error which
by independence equals the product of no
error on each gate
okay so xcb is the proxy of fidelity so
let's plot xcb
and frb is this product equation so
let's plot frb
if these two things coincide and agree
with each other this would suggest that
the hypothesis in the beginning that
noise was uncorrelated
and this would be great news because
this would mean that it is easier for
them to do air correction in the future
so there are two things happening here
in this google's claim
so so the first thing is that they are
making the observation that the linear
cross entropy
agrees with the digital error model in
their experiments
and second
based on this observation google makes
the claim that this coincidence
indicated that the noise in their device
is unqualified and correlated across
each 2kbit case
so
from the
from the theoretical perspective this
seems quite mysterious
so can we try to understand this
observation and the claim from the
theoretical perspective better
and furthermore
can we actually turn this observation as
a hint of a scalable noise benchmarking
algorithm that actually works for
non-clipper gates
so this is precisely
what we do next
so we were able to answer both questions
positively
so the result is the following
we showed that in a noisy circuit there
are evidence showing that the linear
place entropy roughly scales as e to the
minus t times d
where t is the total amount of noise in
the noise model acting on each layer of
case
and therefore we can learn the number t
by measuring the linear cross entropy at
different circuit depths
and as a corollary
we also show that if the noise was
correlated in google's experiment the
linear cross entropy would deviate from
the digital error model frb
and this can be viewed as evidence that
supports google's claim
so let's take a closer look at how this
works so we still work in the same
polyerror channel and the goal is to
estimate the total error
so what we actually show is evidence
that the average fidelity of random
circuits at depth d
scales as this exponential decay
and in experiments we can use xcd as a
proxy for fidelity
and then get the total error t
in other words
for a random circuit c the ideal output
state is just this pure state but in
actual experiments it is a mixed state
and the fidelity is these inner products
and our theorem is to show evidence that
the average fidelity has this
exponential decay
when the total area of t is a small
constant
and the proof idea is to
map this average quantity into the
cartesian function of classical speed
model and then found it analytically
so here is what the actual experiment
looks like
so we just select a few different
circuit depths and sample a few random
circuits at each steps
and then we can estimate the fidelity of
each circuit using the linear cross
entropy and compute the average and
finally fit this exponential decay
and obtain the number t
so here is this coefficient a plays the
similar row as the noise contribution
from the initial states and measurements
so these points
you might be wondering um why do we need
to involve this linear question why
don't we measure fidelity directly
this is just simply because fidelity is
hard to estimate in general because the
direct velocity estimation algorithm has
exponential sample capacity in the worst
case
and therefore we need to borrow the
intuition from google's experiments that
the linear cross entropy appears to be a
sample efficient estimator fidelity with
only one or epsilon square scaling
and recently there has been a lot of
progress showing theoretical evidence of
this
intuition when the total error is small
and this has been obtained by dozer
under jones brandon
as well as gotel
so now this really keeps uh completes
the reasoning that in the second step we
use linear cross entropy as a proxy for
fidelity and obtain the total error at
the end
okay
so we basically have answered the second
question by
showing a noise benchmarking algorithm
for non-clipper case
and now let's go back to this first
question of understanding google's claim
that their noise was unquality
so recall that what happened is that
the linear quadrantity agrees with this
product equation frb
and the claim is that the noise is
uncorrelated
so to understand this claim which we can
just go back to the first example we saw
and
so on the left hand side we have this
independent uncorrelated noise model and
on right hand side we have this
correlated noise model
so if we use rcs benchmarking to learn
the total error
we'll be able to see that the left hand
side has total arrow two percent and the
right hand side has total arrow one
percent
so
in other words
the in the left hand side the noise
model contributes two percent in the
exponential decay of cross entropy and
fidelity
on the other hand it also contributes
two percent to the product equation frb
because we just have two errors which
is one percent
and on the right hand side
this total error is only one percent so
it only contributes one percent to cross
entry and fidelity
however
because of the fact that
we are not distinguishing between the
two noise models by the local
benchmarking
this still contributes two percent to
the product equation frb
so what is happening here is that
frb overestimates correlative noise
because it counts it twice on two gates
so to confirm this we can perform an
absolutely trivial simulation with a
contrived noise model that is highly
correlated across the entire system and
we can say we can see that the frb
equation
decays much much faster than the linear
cross entropy and the fidelity
but we also know that in google's
experiment somehow these
things are
coinciding with each other quite well
and based on our previous discussion
this can be viewed as evidence that
supports google schools claim that the
noise in their device was encoded
so here's the conclusion
uh we developed a sample efficient
algorithm to estimate the total noise
including all of the crosstalks on a
layer of alarm clipper to the case
and of course this doesn't scale beyond
50 qubits because the algorithm does
require classical simulation
and as an application we provide formal
evidence to support google's claim that
the coincidence between linear cross
entry and fidelity
and digital error model indicated that
the noise in their device was unquality
so here's a summary of the
entire part
so we we have shown that for clifford
gates the cycle space of the pattern
transfer graph determines which part of
the noise model is learnable
and this also shows that cycle bench
writing learns all learnable information
and if time permits we can also discuss
ways to resolve anonymity by making
additional assumptions for non-preferred
gates we show how to learn the total
error by introducing random circuit
sampling as a powerful new tool
and this can be viewed as a practical
application of quantum supremacy
experiments and the final question from
here is that whether random circuit
sampling can be used to obtain more
information about noise and there has
been some reason interesting effort from
ibm
here's the references
uh thanks for listening and i can take
uh questions and it's time for me so i
can go back to this first question
any questions
and i'm just wondering if there's
like a better
simulation algorithm without researching
classic circuits
that just have a single layer
yeah so the main problem here is that a
single layer is not sufficient for
benchmarking because we need to apply
many many layers in order to extract the
information
and because we need to alternate between
different patterns right so this just
makes the
circuit harder to simulate as in the
quantum systems
i wonder what kind of uh assumptions are
reasonable for example uh is that
reasonable to assume all single
duplicates play for the ball and
yeah that's that is a reasonable
assumption
the other one is that you have a let's
consider a two qubit
example
that uh
you have a controlled one
and apply it not on two and the other
way
which is control down like two applied
to one uh should i really think that the
error channels for these two
different c notch gates are completely
independent or if there's a some
relation great question so that depends
on your physical mechanism so for
example in some platforms the c naught
gate is just the cc gate with some
harmonic base right but because the c
gate is symmetric so basically the two c
not getting two directions they are
actually the same gates
and so we just model them as having some
noise channel for the one gate and the
other gate can be derived but it could
be the case that there are actually
different physical mechanisms for the
two types of c not and in that case we
can model it as two different noise
channels
if the c naught is implemented c z which
is symmetric uh does it change your
runnability result oh this result also
applies to c gate showing that there is
also two anonymous degrees of freedom
okay so maybe
i can quickly sketch
what are the possible ways to actually
avoid this another ability issue
so the first idea is absolutely simple
which is to observe that this anonymity
doesn't apply if the initial state is
perfect right because from the top
equation we can see that if the initial
state is perfect there's no way to move
it by the gauge transformation however
we did this in experiments
and the it doesn't really work and we
end up concluding that the state primary
noise is not small in the experiments we
performed but it doesn't mean that in
future experiments that this couldn't be
a reasonable approximation
and the second idea i think it was asked
is to use
quantum non-demolition measurements
this just means that maybe in the future
we could have quantum measurements that
also saves the measurement state
and in this way we can break the
framework of current experiments and do
something like this
where we just repeat the measurements
many times also interleave it together
with the gates and in this way we can
break the symmetry between instead pref
still
privilege and measurements and this
could be used to learn more information
about noise that was unknowable in the
top
experiment model
and the third idea
is simply to parameterize the noise
model using the underlying physics we
could for example write down some
hamiltonians and link variants for the
noise model that could have much less
than four billion parameters in general
and maybe in this way
the cycle space already
contains sufficient information to
recover the hamiltonian
and that's all i have thanks for
attention
any more questions
that's the last one for today